Shawn hi hi
so inventor of the hottest dating app in
the world I think six billion matches to
date thanks to you that boy so you've
made six billion matches effectively
down to you and there's 1 million new
users every week and apparently I don't
know if this is true but tinder is
operational in every country in the
world yes
tinder works in in over 196 countries so
tell us fast how you came up with the
idea for tinder I think meeting new
people has always been important part of
humanity but it's always been like a
daunting challenging process like you
see somebody that you want to get to
know and you have to walk up to them and
you might get rejected or it might not
be the right timing because the the
context isn't there and we set out on
wheat you know we had this vision of
basically breaking down all those
barriers and making it super fun super
easy for people to me and we started
tinder for that reason and I think like
you said now there's over 6 billion
matches that have happened on sinners
actually it's actually nearing 10
billion we say 6 billion but publicly
but that number keeps growing and those
are you know over 10 billion connections
that would have otherwise never have
existed or not for you know this this
ambitious group back in LA so I think I
want to talk I caused the success is
astonishing given that tinder was only
launched in 2012 were you influenced at
all by grinder which is the gay hook-up
site that was set up in 2000
I think so um no no I we we do something
very different right not just not just
the context and category but the
application and the product works very
differently um it was was more
influenced by actually real-world
scenarios so you know there was there
was a moment where I was sitting with my
friends in a restaurant this is kind of
where where it all clicked and you know
we were on our phones and ever nobody
was talking to each other eight people
everyone's on their phone in like 2012
this was this was crazy to see now it's
that's what everyone does and and there
was in what we were doing were was
trying to get girls to come join us but
there was a group of girls right next to
us and I just didn't understand why we
don't talk to them and then I started to
notice some of the barriers and
everything but there was this moment
where I looked at one of the girls
across the room and she looked at me
back and I was like whoa that just
solved all the problems because now I'm
not afraid to talk to her she was it was
an invite by both of us so I was like
why don't we just make an app that does
that that recreates that moment and if
you can do that whether it's in business
romance anything prequalify relationship
you remove all the barriers eliminating
the the rejection the rejection and
making it fun yeah I think meeting new
people should be fun it's a part of life
and I know you've talked about tinder
going beyond romance becoming an app
that does something more than that what
does that mean and what's the ultimate
vision I think the ultimate vision is to
be the place you go to when you want to
meet somebody new and to sort of make
these connections that that that are
unspoken for and I think right now we're
doing that very well when it comes to
dating in romance but people are
amazingly already using tinder for more
than that so we call hacking tinder
internally you will see users traveling
the world they will they will match with
locals to find out basically get local
recommendations
they'll make friends when they move into
a new town because it's just such an
efficient way of meeting new people that
people start
using it for a variety of reasons over
time you know we're learning from that
and you know I think we're constantly
thinking about how we can optimize the
product to support some of those
experiences but we're not there yet
we I think the ambition exists it's just
we got to kind of go a step at a time I
was interested because I know that today
is operational everywhere in the world
and I was interested how it how it
functions in a more socially
conservative country like Saudi Arabia
Iran Pakistan any of those countries but
anecdotally I heard that it is being
used more as a social networking tool in
those countries than a hookup it's it's
being used I think I think first of all
it's solving a universal problem doesn't
matter where you live who you are how
old you are I think it lowers the
barriers to meeting somebody which I
think everyone can make yourself and
then I think culturally yes there's
different you know every product is used
differently based on where you are and I
think you know that it's too early to
tell what's happening in you know what
are the exact nuances but we do see some
differences in the meaning that tinder
has to various audiences I know that
what tinder everyone here is it's a free
app but you've partially monetized it
you've given you can pay for advanced
usage I understand that you can there's
the past you couldn't you can rewind and
there's tinder Plus which means that you
can hook up with you can make contact
with people in other countries before
you actually go there other any other
plans to monetize it or anything else in
the well so I think we're gonna we're
going to expand the tinder plus offering
um we're so excited because we you know
tinder is still free and then we
launched a set of features that kind of
superpowers as we like to look at it
that people can leverage if they want
and you don't have to use it but we take
it very seriously that people are paying
us for for an advanced feature set on
tinder and we're going to constantly
evolve that so I think the focus when
you think about revenue is making tinder
even more valuable as we go and we're
gonna continuously add a bunch to that I
have some suggestions fantastic I loved
it haha I've had a little experiment on
the way here yeah I think they shouldn't
just be a yes or a no slide that this
might say something more about me but I
think they should definitely a maybe
swipe rig is like ARP or something is
that just why are you so indecisive
maybe that's the thrill you got say no
forever or yes um and also I thought
maybe a tinder rating like you have a
rubra rating only have like a tinder
rating for like cover some weirdos and
time wasters maybe you know we do we do
have we do have ways of tracking
behavior and actually all the
information we gather including people's
behaviors and and and how likable they
are on tinder factors in to this
algorithm that we use to rank people and
make them relevant kind of how Google
has an algorithm so it's not random how
you select the people that you met so
because I've noticed I've got guy on the
way here I saw no there were loads of
Pakistanis I thought how did they know
that I've got a Pakistani is free
there's lots of people with beards that
was there is it's not random
there there there is a lot of
intelligence that goes into how we
generate these recommendations but
ultimately it's the user it's you that
gets to curate your experience and I
think you know the brilliance of tinder
aside from you know what happens behind
the scene is that we've made it so easy
for you to say yes or no that you can
actually pick and you're in control of
your experience which I think you know
other products you think about it's like
things are pushed to you but with tinder
there's this like symbiotic relationship
that the user has with the interface but
is how easy it is and the the number of
options you have is there a danger in
you know
making perhaps making us so dissatisfied
because the grass is always greener does
it undermine long-term relationships and
commitment because there's always a
sense that oh well there's someone else
I could just swipe away well I think
first of all there's countless marriages
that have resulted from tinder and
friendships and everything but I
actually fear a world where you don't
have options because then you have to
settle with what you have and you might
not be happy in the relationship gone
but you don't leave the relationship no
I think I think I think the beauty of
tinder is it gets you to the point where
you're like oh my god that's the one and
I don't want it I don't want anyone else
maybe that's how you could love it first
white yeah I mean I might be a romantic
but I do think that that that there is a
one that sort of stops you from thinking
about everyone else and I think when you
do have that option ality you get to
that point sooner and you don't have to
settle for somebody who you know a lot
of people are in unhappy relationships
because they feel like they don't have
options so I think you can flip that
around um I was really interested in the
fact that you have now a full-time
researcher who analyzes all the data
that you've obviously accumulated you
have this massive treasure trove of data
what are you going to do with that data
and what is it telling us about the
human condition so it's it's - it's
early to tell I think the challenge for
us has been first effectively capturing
that data in a safe way and now that
we've done that now the fun starts now
we have a team of data scientists so in
a sociologist as you mentioned that's
sort of looking at this data and trying
to make a better product and I think
ultimately what it's being used for
right now is to make better
recommendations to our users on who they
see and then there's there's definitely
there's anecdotal data and stuff where
we find I would say various patterns
between different groups and geography
and gender that I think are interesting
but it's too early to share any of those
you can share what the do's and don'ts
of a successful profile are what are the
yeah how do you create the perfect
profile
I have some insight on that I think I
think the perfect profile is somebody
really being who they are right now it's
not a headshot actually we do have data
that headshots don't work that well
because doesn't say anything about your
personality but we can capture a lot out
of the photos that we see so I think
photos that show a person's energy their
interests those work very well
apparently people with with Tigers
what's our your prank that's been banned
in New York it was banned in New York
yeah well because with pikas
there's a lot of memes on tinder but uh
you know there's in LA we have people we
take pictures at the lock apparently
there's like tons of those into a no
model email why the only mail headshots
but believe it or not it's not a
successful on tinder because it's not
the it doesn't give you an indication of
who the person is it's a very staged
persona and I think we're very
intelligent when it comes to
interpreting photos and we can capture
those nuances and I think the most
remarkable thing that we've learned you
know partially anecdotally partially
through some of the data we look at is
that we are very intelligent and
perceptive when it comes to photos
especially now we're inundated with so
much in social media we can interpret
very quickly in a split second we can we
can get a better first impression that I
believe you can get in the real world by
just seeing somebody across the room I
know we've got to wrap up in a minute
but your I know that you're no longer
CEO even though you founded the company
and I can just tell us how that came
about and and and what your role is now
and how it's changed so I'm the
president now and I'm focusing a lot of
my time on product I think that's that's
where my passions lies on building
better products for for our community
and our users and Christopher Payne just
joined us as a CEO and he sort of
helping scale the business and and run
the company we have an awesome
relationship so I think it's been it's
been amazing for me because I get to
focus on product do the things I love
and I get to learn from somebody
remarkable to leave
business forward do I get to ask two
more questions nope that's it sorry
everyone
thank you so much all right